all right
okay uh so I've been told I I'm the
moderator so I give away to you and uh
to the rest
okay so
um
they are all on behalf of this and the
group
um I'm glad to welcome you to the
worship treaty changes our Progressive
Vision following the conference on the
future of Europe
which is uh organized by the uh
snd working group in the Constitutional
Affairs committee
and uh with Gabby Bishop our vice
president for this topic among others
in the group
I'm very happy to see such a large
audience many of you have
registered 90 participants so I think
this is uh this is showing the
the importance of the topic and the
interest that the worship has raised and
also a special thanks to our
stakeholders and strategic partners that
are also present apart from of course
um group members
uh and not only from AFCO vice president
Mark Angel Margarita Marquez Pedro Silva
also vice president and member of the
AFCO team ICL supervan Perez who is
participating later former MEP so
as you know in these legislative in this
legislature we have experienced the
conference on the future of Europe which
has been an Innovative tool of
participation and the liberative
Democracy as you know as a result of
this exercise
I will say
um
far-reaching in the good sense of the
word proposals have come out of this
conference in terms of more I will say
more Europe in terms of uh capabilities
to act
vis-a-vis the main transnational
challenges but also better Europe in
terms of more democratic and more
efficient in its uh decision making and
in its legitimacy
and
we have as a political group been a
strong supporter of the process of the
conference and also of following up on
the conference and this is why we have
had also
um and we have no not in the past uh
Gabby Bischoff as the Sandy Cora Porter
precisely on the report that the
parliament is elaborating on amendments
to the treaties it is very clear that we
need to have a convention
to
implement the outcome of the conference
in these two Dimensions more Europe more
social Europe more environmental Europe
but also more democratic Europe
and in this regard of course the Spanish
presidency of the European Union will be
um we believe critical in moving the
timeline and the process uh forward so
without uh
more uh substance I'm happy to give the
floor uh to Gabby Bishop as I said group
vice president and also for reporter of
the report on the reform of the treaties
thank you Don Dominic and good morning
everyone it's so good to see you all in
the room I see so many comrades friends
members of the progressive caucus uh of
the conference on the future of Europe
that it's a pleasure to be here with you
and discuss where we are standing and
also our strategy for the next steps
indeed as vice president of the group
here and also being one of the six core
operators on the report we are working
on at the moment to amend the treaties
uh it is especially good to debate here
with distinguished experts we have
invited here but also with you all
um that are interested and I think we as
asnd group we always had a strong vision
for a social and Democratic Europe we
wouldn't have needed the conference on
the future of Europe but we appreciated
it and we initiated it because we wanted
to have a bottom-up approach year for
the necessary reforms and this is why in
all the work we are doing that the
starting point for us are the
recommendations of this conference on
the future of Europe here to reform the
EU
um and also to propose changes in the
different policy areas because we still
think that the conference offered a
unique opportunity here for
institutional representatives for
Citizens for civil society social
Partners here to come up with strong
proposals and we have to say when we had
the idea the parliament pushing for
involvement of citizens in this way we
couldn't have anticipated that already
the process the time when we do the
conference would already start important
changes because it was really an
unprecedented situation on one hand
first we had covet
and within this experience already some
taboos broke regarding the road to an
economic Union
the citizens were debating coming up
with proposals but we could already see
um changes happening also in the
competence of Health I think everyone
understood after this pandemic that we
need especially in cross-border
situations like a pandemic that we need
more competences here that we would be
much better capable to act and faster
here and then we had the Russian
aggression and the war against Ukraine
here which also showed and demonstrated
concretely the importance of strategic
autonomy and with this also the goals of
establishing an energy Union for example
or a common defense policy and and that
was also the key point in the conference
our decision making capacities we can
see that the support of citizens is
growing again
but that it also depends on the Union's
capacity to act in difficult situations
and that it can show citizens that they
are better off as European citizens in
the European Union than there would be
only with national Solutions and I think
that is a good starting point a good
basis for us on the work we are doing at
the moment finding compromises in this
house where and how to amend the
treaties so this called really for
Extraordinary and Joint European
Solutions but at the same time
I think we have to say if we look at the
49 proposals they were already quite
anticipatory quite Progressive also
because they say okay we want results we
want to strengthen the use capacity to
act
especially in areas where it's not the
case for example and also become fairer
more sustainable or use a whole
generation is on the streets in many
member states to say we need faster
Solutions here digital with a stronger
voice also in the world
so and when we look at our political and
financial means we can see that yet the
EU is not equipped sufficiently and this
is why we embarked on this journey we as
snd played really a crucial role also
here in driving the parliament's
position on the future of Europe also
after the resolution we didn't rely
already uh calling for a European
convention we are now working indeed
very hard in the AFCO report we have to
finish it next week we still have some
way to go
um but we aim really at presenting it in
the plenary in July
we cannot miss this opportunity here to
enter a new phase of European
integration and a process with ambitious
reform I think everyone agrees almost
everyone that these times of muddling
through are over
and to our view institutional reforms
are a precondition for making the EU
more social more sustainable cohesive
and accountable and strengthened by
directly engaging citizens through
participatory mechanisms we will also
explore further in in the future and
this is why we are delighted to have so
many people here not only experts
distinguished experts but only active
citizens active representatives of ngos
of organizations
that share the same vision that we have
and also to engage in a common
discussion here
um how we can uh how we can introduce
this necessary institutional changes
also and to implement the political
goals that we have so I will try and not
to bore you and already with quick
overview of some priorities we will be
proposing in the framework of the AFCO
report I said it's not finished yet but
we already have some common lines here
and and also with some of the points
that are really key to our heart as snd
group because we were driving very much
also for changes in Social and economic
issues but also energy Health gender
equality and not to mention also really
some institutional changes necessary so
I will just highlight some points I'm
sure we will have time also with the
expats to go into more details one thing
that the citizens gave us as an overall
task is to say come on let's move to
qualified majority in almost all policy
areas
because the way decisions are done is
not working anymore with 27 and this is
something also where we have a
compromise of all pro-european political
parties in this house to do so and I
think this would be a major step forward
the incorporation of the social progress
protocol and also the social pillar into
the treaties was a key element and I
think every political group in this
house knew we wouldn't go along if we
wouldn't get this
um so I think this is also in terms of
social Europe a major progress a new
shared competences in public health
matters I mentioned it the experience of
the pandemic was very clear here
um and it helped uh also to to come on
on a joint positions here
um also new exclusive competences on the
fight against climate change is
essential we know it we owe it to the
next Generation so I hope we are going
to do that and the stronger role of the
P for a full a more Democratic Union
right of initiative right of inquiry on
electoral law
this was something also the citizens
gave us in their package of 49 proposals
said this is something that needs to be
done also stronger powers of the
parliament in the budget procedures is a
key element also for a more Democratic
Union and last but not least and with
this I will I will close here is we we
fight in this house jointly
um for rule of law for democracy for
respect here uh and we need more
effective procedures on article 7 for
breaches of EU values and this is also
something we are going to propose here
and I will end with for us gender
equality and a stronger base is legal
basis for anti-discrimination is key
this is also something that we have in
this package hopefully I mean everything
is agreed when the package is finalized
but I am optimistic then that we can go
here we have other areas where we still
have to work over the weekend next week
but I'm confident that we will manage to
have a package
um that can open this new chapter of
integration but I know also this is just
the first step
of the game because I think we need all
of you we need everyone to put up the
pressure on the council to start the
next phase that we will have a
convention and this is when the real
work starts as I'm going to say it so I
wish everyone
um here in to be good involved in these
debates and I will hand over back to
Dominic as moderator to say I'm very
pleased to be here with you and debate
with you thank you very much
uh things a lot Gabby
um also for the concrete
um
achievements uh that you outlined uh
that are going to be in the report uh
and that we have been fighting for as a
political family uh even before the
conference because we had a similar
seminar as this one maybe some of you
remember uh Maria you were there also
with the study from Phipps and uh there
was this snd paper with ideas for the
conference like the ones Gabby just
mentioned climate neutrality to be
instrument in the treaty the
incorporation of the social pillar into
the treaty so we're making progress huh
so what it first is a is a policy paper
for the from the group that then is
going to be part of the parliament
position
for the triggering of article 48. now
um we are starting the first panel
um with Maria Joe Rodriguez and John
Paul jacke thank you for uh being here
with us uh Maya joao is I think very
well known but nonetheless uh I will
remind that is the president of phebs
which is our theme tank of the European
social Democrats and uh has been also
MEP I'm vice president of snd group in
the previous uh term and you have been
working a lot from the fep site
producing uh to us one study already
which is the one outside and one in the
making uh so um which is also fitting
into our policy process and our
proposals uh for the next phase which is
um the convention so uh thanks very much
Maria joao for being with us and um the
flourishers
many many Thanks for for for this
invitation and uh well this is a great
initiative as a Dominic and uh Gabby are
just introducing this topic such an
important initiative
because in fact we start some time ago
and
in the meantime it was possible to
launch the conference on the future of
Europe and the Portuguese presidency it
was possible to unblock the situation we
had many skeptical people by that time
but then in the end it proved to be a
very important process of a
participatory democracy
and we could see that there is a lot of
common ground between European citizens
and there is really a lot of common
Vision about what should be the next
phase of the European project
so in the end it proves a very
interesting experience and that's why
now the European Parliament is honoring
the expectation created by the future of
Europe by preparing these reports very
important reports led by AFCO committee
but involving many other Committees of
the department and
um the approach uh proposed by the
citizens I believe it was quite wise
because they wanted a Europe delivering
on their concerns on their aspirations
and then they said well sometimes we can
do it under the Lisbon treaty
but we also need to recognize that for
other purposes the Lisbon treaty has
some limits
this was in general the conclusion of
the conference of the future of Europe
and that's why a department decide to
move ahead with these reports and now we
have this Workshop as a input in the in
the much larger process
so
um
in the meantime
we could also ask
but is all these still
viable
because we have a completely different
context
notably created by The Invasion Ukraine
by Russia and everything stemming from
this
is this still viable
well let me tell you one minute story
what happened to us in Lisbon when we
were preparing a Portuguese presidency
and we had just lost the Constitutional
treaty
after the negative referendum in the in
France and Netherlands and everybody was
saying forget it we cannot have a new
treaty
but I can tell you that in the meantime
we were really hoping for the
opportunity and when the opportunity
came under the the Portuguese presidency
we were prepared we had technically
a proposal prepared and that's why the
Lisbon treaty became possible so this is
a lesson I think we should have in mind
now it seems that perhaps it's not so
viable but for my viewpoint the question
is is this necessary this is the
important question is this necessary
well
um in our European Foundation Fabs we
have conducted an exercise
involving high-level expertise exactly
to assess precisely the potential of the
audition treaty if we can do it with the
Lisbon treaty this is great
but sometimes we could also identify
where are the limits and my intervention
today will be about the limits because
well I know that I need to be very short
well we concluded that there are five
main reasons
why you should
improve uh the treaty
um and first of all with an approach
which consists of
upgrading competencies
from complementary competencies to
Shared competencies and sometimes from
shared competencies to exclusive
competencies
this is a a method a second method Gabby
just referred to this is to extend the
so-called ordinary legitative procedure
meaning qualified majority voting in the
council plus co-decision
competencies attributed to the European
Parliament
so this is the how
we could go beyond the Lisbon treaty
now let me be concrete about what should
be upgraded
the first reason
is because in fact we are dealing with a
completely different uh International
environment
and we need to upgrade competencies
regarding
European
um external action as a whole including
when negotiating for instance the the
climate agreements in cop we need to
have a much better coordinated position
but certainly when it comes foreign
affairs
because we need to have
a special kind of qualified majority not
the general one but the super qualified
majority voting should be the solution
to overcome the risk of Vetoes because
we have been dealing with the vetoes
during particularly the invasion of
Ukraine by Russia
and there is a second
concern here is the so-called in fact
strategic autonomy because we need to
have strategic autonomy
um when it comes cyber security when it
comes industrial policy food security
there are different dimensions where we
have been seen during the war that in
fact we need to have
stronger competences to decide and to
act
so all in all this is the first reason
we need to improve the treaty
then there is a second one which is
we need to have a stronger Democratic
capacity to shape the green transition
and the digital transition with social
cohesion this is our let's say
development model
and for the next phase of European
project many decisions need to be taken
in this direction
so example we should move to Shared
competencies when it comes industrial
policy when it comes to as European
Networks
and it will be easier to deliver real
trans European Networks
on the digital
area let me remind that in the Lisbon
treaty we don't have the word digital
when we concluded the the listen treaty
the digital transformation was taking
shape but it was the beginning
so our conclusion is that we should
introduce a new title in the treaties
dealing with digital policies
and then on the social Dimension yes
with the social pillar we have conducted
in fact a qualitative lip
comprehending all the social policies
for All European citizens so this is a
major transformation of the social
Dimension and in fact this should be
translated in
um a general uh
legislative
procedure for all social policies which
are in our side the employment the
social protection uh the uh in including
in-house in education we need to improve
because in certain aspects of Health
policy and of Education policy we should
move from complementary competencies
towards uh shared competencies
and then we have a third reason very
important is to have the means to
deliver all this meaning the budgetary
capacity
and we suggest that when it comes to
reform of the stability and growth Pact
we should have a kind of golden rule
with a precise approach which is to
focus precisely on the delivering
European public goods which should be
identified by European institutions as
priority public goods a good example
happened during the pandemics in fact
because we create more fiscal room at
National level to finance Health
spending this is extremely good example
on how we can
introduce a wise Golden Rule compatible
with fiscal responsibility
but this is not enough we should in fact
create a permanent stronger European
budgetary capacity
backed by
um
the capacity of the European Union to
borrow
so we should introduce in the treaties a
specific provision
creating a European capacity to borrow
provided this is fully backed by
european-owned resources this is a very
precise condition
which brings us to the problem-bound
resources because on resources should
also be adopted by the normal
legislative procedure
um finally when it comes taxation we
need to introduce new sources of
Taxation but you also need to introduce
the piece of tax coordination the cost
of the tax coordination is not clear
enough in the in the Lisbon in the
Lisbon treaty
the first reason is uh the Democratic
one very important starting with the
rule of law
so introducing a more clear mechanism to
impose uh Respect by for the rule of law
but also improving our representative
democracy the role of departments in the
budgetary decisions
the need to improve the European
electoral system
and also introducing participatory
democracy at all levels as the concept
of future Bureau has proved that she's
such a great potential to have these
large participation of citizens
um final reason why
this is the famous equation of the
European integration
enlargement versus deepening well in
fact this is not not about either or we
need both we need enlargement
enlargement now is political in fact a
moral imperative because we need to
um
protect and give a perspective to the
European countries fighting for
democracy close to our borders
but we also know that in order to have
enlargement without paralyzing European
union we need to introduce some
institutional reforms and that's why we
need the deepening I was calling for
my final conclusion is the following
the approach we are suggesting
uh
is based on a fundamental idea is that
for next phase of the European project
we can no longer conduct the European
ambition just with the technocratic
approach we need to base this phase on
much stronger European citizenship
from my viewpoint this is the central
concepts of the next phase
uh
and the I believe it's possible to have
stronger support of European citizens
regarding the European projects
if we involve them
much better at all levels
from the local to the European
if we prove that we can decide and act
to protect European citizens in our
external action across the world
but mainly because we can deliver real
deliver new European public goods
meeting their aspirations and their
concerns and let me conclude with some
concrete examples let's imagine that
Europe
with the capacity to decide
and to act
on building real trans European Networks
for the energy transition for the green
economy
for the
open access to the digital
transformation
let's imagine that we have a real
European cloud and data space
let's imagine that we can have
artificial intelligence supporting
European Public Services
let's imagine that we can count
on
European
degrees and the European open University
and let's imagine that we can count on a
much more projects of European public
interest
delivering smart Investments better jobs
and finally let's imagine that we have a
Europe delivering
a social pillar in all fronts for all
citizens
and notably with the
the flagships we have created the youth
initiative use guarantee child guarantee
mini income minimum wage and John access
to social protection
all these requires
some
Target changes in the Lisbon treaty it's
not the complete transformation I'm
meaning
a short list of Target changes but they
can't really make a difference so this
was the conclusion of our expert group
and many things for our collaboration
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a lot to say but we will save it
for the debate I will not abused my
position as moderator and I I give the
floor now to
professor John Paul Jake who is a
professor at the College of Europe and
he's a leading expert on legal and
institutional
questions or topics
so please Professor the first years
and thank you for being with us
thank you very much I was sent quite a
broad list of speaking points obviously
I won't be able to cover them all
amongst all of the proposals for
revising the treaties which have been
made I think it's important to
distinguish two categories here the
institutional category that I will touch
on later
and those that affect specific areas
such as enlarging competences or other
areas
I think amongst these different issues
relating to competences that I have read
there are different types of proposals
some are
purely decorative they actually Express
things which are already covered in the
treaties
I have no objection to adding this extra
layer of decoration so to speak to the
treaties but I don't think it's really
necessary
trans European
networks for example is this something
that affects digital no
these are different things that we have
to identify
so there are things that are nice that
are pretty to write into the treaties
but they're not really getting to the
heart of the debate
on the areas where we really could do
more I would like to draw your attention
to changes in categories for the
competences
now we do need to see those changes but
where are they really necessary and
where could they be counterproductive
I saw that there was unanimous support
to include environment amongst the eu's
exclusive competences
now I am not against this but we need to
look carefully at the consequences that
this might have when you have an
exclusive competencies the member states
no longer have the right to intervene
when it comes to areas of exclusive
competence then the principle of
subsidiary no longer plays a role
so you will deprive the member states of
any possibility of acting individually
here and if the EU chooses not to act
then the member states don't have the
right to do anything
so I would suggest that we think very
carefully
about how we would word what is going to
be an exclusive confidence because we
don't want to have any counterproductive
effects here
I would also like to raise another point
because I think it is interesting
amongst these proposals
there is a proposal made in the
interests of these citizens a small
modification to an article related to
the court of justice
that allows the citizens to challenge
Union decisions when they are
individually and directly concerned by
such judgments
because this would be limiting the
um effects of citizens when it comes to
challenging rulings but if we do change
this what would the effects be now
citizens aren't necessarily informed of
these uh rulings
they're not going to go to the EU course
they're going to go to the National
courts to challenge these rulings but
they will not be valid in those National
jurisdictions they will be told why
didn't you challenge that directly at
the European court of justice
so by trying to do something for the
citizens without fundamentally really
understanding what the consequences of
that will be you can again have
counterproductive effects
so I think you need to be
extremely cautious when it comes to
looking at these uh competences
and looking at how
this what the technical impacts of this
will be so you do need to have those
changes but you need to do that very
cautiously
if you
want to change things that are already
existing that's one thing but otherwise
I think we need to be extremely Vigilant
now for health I think we do need to see
a change in the category there for
industry again I think that's something
that we can consider
in the area of social matters we
certainly should enlarge the competences
but we do need to think about the
long-term consequences of what we are
doing to how avoid possibly damaging
consequences
so
I have begun there by urging caution I
know that you are cautious so perhaps
that warning isn't necessary but I
wanted to say it nevertheless
let us think now about the institutions
I think and you're probably all in
agreement here we uh do not create
institutions for the sake of it
I think any change to the institutions
has to have a purpose
it's not simply for the intellectual
satisfaction of having created uh
something nice or attractive it has to
be something that is functional
so I share your views but I would
perhaps make an additional uh point of
caution here
we have an
overall institutional framework that is
based on a twofold legitimacy first of
all that of the member states and of the
direct legitimacy of the European
Parliament is that something we wanted
to change certain suggestions uh
it makes me think we want to move to a
completely parliamentary system
[Music]
and compared to the federal aspect so we
need to think carefully about what we
want here by reinforcing the parliament
uh we then reducing the role of the
member states within the system
or are we talking about a necessary
rebalancing of the system
and that is something that we need to
bear in mind when we look at these
reform proposals what type of system do
we want do we want to have a balanced
federal system or do we want to move to
a more parliamentarian system that then
erases the federal aspects
so a rebalancing means limiting the
powers of council that's not surprising
I think that has always been the wish of
the institution where we are here today
rebalancing the council's powers how
would that be done
well
would that be qualified uh majority uh
for example in every aspect where we can
so I've read certain drafts that have
been circulating
this is a question of touching up the
treaties and Crossing out unanimity and
changing that for qualified majority
wherever possible
so this might be necessary but the rules
themselves will not lead to the change
you want so you might change the rules
but you should not be naive when looking
at the reality here
what
is going to make the difference here are
the practices rather than the rules now
you might welcome this or regret this
depending what side you're on but
despite the rules in the cases where
Council has to agree by qualified
majority voting according to the most
recent uh calculations in over 83
percent of the cases de facto those
decisions are made in a unanimous way so
you might write qualified majority
voting everywhere you wish but the rule
that will apply in practice in Council
is still that of the common accor
so
we
should be aware of what our words
actually mean now am I saying this is
useless no
a rule can be imposed in extreme cases
now of course the council will always
try and agree based on consensus but
there may be cases where decisions have
to be made because that is imposed on
them by the political situation and
there might be one country that is
particularly uh recalcitrant or hesitant
but
I don't think we can hope for more than
that moving to qualified majority voting
I believe is necessary
but
do not think that that will lead to a
more generalized use of qualified
majority voting it is simply going to be
something used in the most extreme cases
although that is already a good thing I
agree with what you're saying
there are cases when moving to qualified
majority voting has to be applied with
caution I don't want to go into this
again but for example in the area of
foreign policy and security policy
we have talked about the possibility of
reinforced qualified majority voting in
these cases
if in these types of areas we move to a
simple qualified majority voting the
member states simply aren't going to
execute these decisions and they are the
ones that can enforce these decisions so
otherwise it's just going to be
pointless I think one particular example
and I'm sure you'll remember this not in
the area of foreign policy
but was the decision on the
relocalization of migrants this was
adopted by qualified majority voting but
this was never actually implemented
so we need to be
pragmatic do we prefer decisions that
don't actually lead to any
execution in reality so we have the
super qualified majority voting or
a possibility for a member state that
doesn't want to associate itself with
that decision to not participate and to
not Implement these decisions so having
an opt-out for a member State on a
particular decision so these choices are
possible
but I think pesk for a common foreign
security policy that might need separate
treatment
so in the end does this strengthen the
Democratic legitimacy of the EU I don't
think so
I don't think it's through institutional
changes that we create greater
Democratic legitimacy
now we might be very fond of the the
framework the architecture but
sacrificing your life that's something
quite different
so I think that there are
simpler ways to enforce Democratic
legitimacy
or
um create it from scratch where it never
really existed
I think having these conventions uh
associating citizens that's important
but if it's not really widely discussed
then what's the point
illegitimacy is achieved through voting
through participation
now
we might regret this but it we are shown
through every crisis that those who have
the real legitimacy are the heads of
state and government
citizens believe that they believe those
are the ones that are responsible for
their future and their uh and their fate
so that is the reality
so how do we move that legitimacy and
confirm more of that onto our
institutions
I think by
creating a stronger political Dimension
to our institutions
I don't
think the institutional changes as I
said are what are going to make the
difference it's about having a greater
political Dimension to our system you
might ask me how we would do that
and I think that's by creating true
European political parties
so moving beyond National political
debates and broadening those and having
political discussions on on true
European
um on a true European scale and when I
say real European political parties
there parties with members that choose
their leaders
and do this very transparently
parties that are able to invest or
co-invest
when it comes to candidates for European
Parliament elections so the Electoral
debate should not be a national
political debate but these European
political parties should be directly
involved and there are ways to do that
and this is not necessarily through a
revision of the treaties
um but that is having transnational
um voting lists and constituencies
so people can vote directly for these
people from European political parties
uh vote for these people who have
campaigned to have Justified their
selection
and I think it is in this way that we
create a true Democratic legitimacy
in our democracies
parties choose who will eventually form
a government
they have a responsibility to educate
their citizens through political debate
and to uh Focus their policies on the
future we do not have Democratic
legitimacy without that true political
uh spirit it's at the moment just
confined to a far away uh framework
in Europe so
we may reform the treaties we might have
institutions in perfect working order
we may face all of the challenges that
arise
but we will not have truly built the
link between us and the citizens and we
will always seem somewhat artificial
thank you very much
[Applause]
uh professor
thank you very much Professor Jackie
of course
just to
we just like to say something to start
out the debate I think
that there is not a contradiction
between working to reform the treaty
uh Gabby and Maria as well explained the
the
idea of this and when you said that you
would agree to go to qualified majority
that would be for extreme cases that's
already something because remember we're
hungry and Poland blogging blocking some
of the recovery plans
now in a case like that
uh if we can
uh use qualified uh majority for the
approval of the uh multi-annual
Financial it would be a very important
Solution One Way Out
but I was saying it there is no
contradiction between finding
new instruments new institutional
instruments like qualified majority and
at the same time I very much agree
we need to get stronger political
processes and the Parliament has made
proposals they're working on the reform
of the treaty with Gabby's report
I was a repertoire on the electoral law
which uh is uh proposing transnational
uh
electoral laws so I think we've got some
complementary aspects thank you again
and I think these are very important
plants
to give us a political vision
which is supported legally
now
we're going to go on to the debate open
the floor here
I see quite a few
Maps I see margarita
mark
margarita
and then we'll
talk to other colleagues and so thank
you very much
I didn't really want to be the first one
to take the floor but as you said there
were several members I thought all the
others would ask for the floor anyway
firstly thank you for organizing this
debate
and I'm sorry Gabby
and Dominique but I'd like especially to
thank Maria Joel and uh
I really think that
these are two contributions which really
tabled and showed how complicated
complex this exercise was going to be
and let me explain why I think that
because when Maria's made her
presentation
uh
for each point what I was doing as an
exercise was to try to
understand whether what Mariah was being
or was proposing could be done within
the Lisbon treaty and this is how I
followed your presentation and I
actually
it could not see
constraints in this treaties which would
preclude developing the policies that
you suggested
now of course some of the points you
raised
uh uh would be clearer if we had targets
or very specific changes in the treaty I
agree with that
and some of the issues you raise and I
I'm sure that you're quite aware of
certain things you're aware that we've
raised these questions already before
the Lisbon treaty at the last convention
all these posts to the Constitutional
treaty to Lisbon treaty we debated this
you and I and others defended principles
that we could not get introduced into
the Lisbon treaty but there is some room
for maneuversal to conclude I should say
that we will make we'll have advantages
if we change certain Target
modifications like the three percent and
the sixty percent of the debt and the
definite deficit in the protocols which
would be annexes to the treaty that's
one good example but going from
unanimity to Quality or absolute
majority you can do it with the bridge
claws we never did it I was Rapport of
the mff and at one point we're trying to
tell the commission if we keep dealing
with this issue we're going to try to
use the bridge Clause now it turned out
not to be necessary
but there was a legal possibility within
the treaty to solve that problem if we
couldn't find consensus
now Mr Jackie what you said well
I think
they're
kind of
throwing cold water on those who want to
who have a vision of a future treaty but
I very much agree with the questions
that uh you mentioned we do have to keep
in mind what we can do and what we can
compare
and what type of revision of the treaty
we can carry out and what the political
priorities are for the citizens
so I think we have to see how we can
deal with the uh
uh political motivations and the will
because this will shape the results
uh as I've been saying we've not been
able to use the bridge Clause we've
never done it member states didn't want
to do it
will they want to do that well they
really want to extend the bridge clause
in a new treaty to actually move from
unanimity to a qualified majority and
then secondly the competence question
and what we're seeing in my prime
minister's raised this question often
what we often see is that
if we draw a map
with the the one by one con competence
that member states want some member
states want to strengthen the political
powers in other areas whereas others
want to cut back on political actions
and this uh you can see this in the
reinforced enforced cooperation exercise
I think one thing is clear for all of us
if we're going to review the treaty and
revise it of course the socialists at
least we as socialists have very
concrete proposals as to how to change
the treaty I was the reporter in the
econ committee
and we made very concrete proposals now
to finish we cannot just leave behind
some of the Ambitions we have
because we are waiting for the treaty to
be changed we've got to use every
possibility within the treaty right now
that we have thank you
okay let's proceed
um but I think we we agree with the last
point it's not one or the other we want
to take advantage to the fullest of the
current constitutional framework but
also we want to go uh farther I think
Mark also wants the floor Pedro but
please because the staff is looking to
me not in a very nice way so keep it
short and then we we have also a very
short reaction from from the panel okay
yes thank you very much I'm happy that
we organized this follow-up of the
conference on the future of Europe and I
recall that this I recall that these 49
proposals are not the initial proposals
of the citizens but they have been they
have been reformulated in a very uh
Democratic way in the working groups
where National parliaments were present
where the council was present where the
commission was present and where many
MEPS were present so these 49 proposals
they have had already been adapted a
little bit and yes we can do a lot of
these proposals in reality with policy
change with legislation but there's this
little bit which is left and I think you
mentioned it very well Maria joao a list
of targeted changes the small list of
targeted changes are are necessary and
and this is also important and because
nobody wants to open a Pandora box but
we have to be very targeted and come
back to these proposals from the
conference on the future of Europe and
then of course
we need to be cautious
we need to be very cautious and any
convention would give us time to discuss
and be cautious and I hope that the next
convention will not be a black room like
the previous convention
but that we will use the model of the
conference on the future of Europe and
that
we will have this convention be rather
more transparent secondly
you spoke about various measures which
are purely decorative they may be
decorative but I would use the term
that they're explicative that many
citizens
in discussions with citizens we've seen
that there's a great deal in the treaty
already
which is not very clear and perhaps to
help this I think
that's why we are also doing this
exercise which may be a little more
decorative and
ever since and social Europe is very
important to us
and the position that Gabby presented
these are very important for our
political family
because I don't want to
hear
anymore when we want to advance the
social Europe there are colleagues in
Parliament who say that Europe has
nothing to say on the social side and
this is something where we need to
really work on this so should I mention
in our treaties and the last point
as I'm very active in
anti-discrimination matters which are
not included in the actual treaty and
when I see Helena Dali the commissioner
for equality she has her hands
um
bind because she cannot she cannot do uh
everything because some of the grounds
of discrimination are not included in
the treaty and in our Charter and
therefore we need to we need to discuss
this thank you
thanks Mark very good points uh Pedro
well first of all let me thank our
guests two topics I would like to raise
one on democracy and the other one on
economic governance
um now on Democracy I fully agree with
the warnings do we really want to
distract this double legitimacy that we
have in the European construction the
trend in the last few years has been to
reinforce the position of the parliament
the role of the parliament and I think
we should continue uh in that path but
what we want from the part of the
council is mostly to avoid a blockage in
the council so that the council can
react and then to
improve the relationship between the
council and the Parliament so that the
parliament is stronger in this
relationship
in fact the reason why people vote Less
in the European elections than in other
elections probably is because they
believe their those European nations are
less important than the national
elections so perhaps there is something
more we could do in order to make people
understand that the parliament is strong
and the vote in the opinion elections uh
is Meaningful it has a consequence on
the way Europe is being governed and who
governs uh in fact Europe so I wonder if
um some movement in that direction uh
would not be important to improve our
democracy then on economic governance
um I was happy to see that the
proposals in this area but are also
surprised because we've been seeing a
battle here in this Parliament about
um fiscal capacity for a long time so I
would be surprised if suddenly uh we can
get a political consensus on a permanent
budgetary capacity although I would
um
welcome that so my question is do you
really think that the permanent
budgetary capacity a capacity of
borrowing based on own resources is
politically viable at this stage and
finally
um I don't see a reference here to the
inclusion in the treaties of the
European stability mechanism which is
still an intergovernmental body there
was the intention to make it part of the
European institutions the fact that it
is not in the list of measures it tell
us something about the lack of political
will to ensure this fiscal capacity and
all the European instruments in terms of
economic governance
thank you very much thank you to those
three colleagues who have taken the
floor we're a little behind
time so I would ask
just come in we'll take you in the next
round
but perhaps you could respond just in
one minute you obviously don't have to
respond to
uh all
of the questions that there's a
particular interest that was raised that
you'd like to touch on if you could
possibly uh cover that in in just one
minute and we'll start with Mr Jackie
okay uh
if for does
in a proposal for revising a treaty
we would do as much as possible and then
we will see
remember Spinelli
and the Spinelli treaty
he asked for as much as possible
and
I had to wait 30 years
for it to be implemented and it was
introduced bit by bit in the treaties up
to Lisbon
so don't be mistaken the key moment for
introducing things is enlargement
and it's since Amsterdam that we've been
reviewing treaties and that we've
had been giving Spinelli to the member
states
in bits
and the process will be the same
so
have a plan
and make them make the member states
swallow it bit by bit over the course of
events and we've not talked about the
rule of law
we talked about whether there was the
things to do
initially
talking about a breaches need to be done
by an independent organization by the
court not the member states
and
once this has been independently stated
the member states will have to take
their responsibilities directly
there won't be discussions over whether
there is a risk of a breach that's a
purely political discussion we take that
away
and just get the sanctions that they
will have to respond to
um
we'll speak about that as well Mary as
well
many things for these very interesting
debate on but I will be very short
um the Pastoral possibility
let me remind that the Pastoral
mechanism is a very complex one
because it requires not only
ratification
endorsement by All European institutions
but by all national parliaments
each item to be exposed to the password
which means that each time we want to
use the Pastoral we need to to ensure
all these large ratification
that's why
uh even it seems very bold
it might be easier to have a convention
with a limited mandate
this is the Paradox of the situation we
are in
which bring me to the issue of
the opportunity because last time we ran
a convention in fact the conversion had
no time to update the treaties
most of the European policies were not
updated
because European Council said to the
convention now you stop
this is the real story
that's why the Brisbane treaty had no
it's not based on a proper updated of
many many European policies
and now they are even more outdated
so my point then this is my my final
proposal is that
let's be prepared
because we never know
if the opportunity comes at least we are
prepared
and that's why this work is so important
and how can the opportunity come look
let me remind what happened to us during
the kovid
it was due to the shock of the pandemic
that finally we could agree on something
we are fighting for during a painful
Eurozone crisis
to have common issues of bonds
this was not possible with the terrible
costs and then it was in front of a
semantic shock with asymmetic impacts
the pandemic that finally this
qualitatively took place
so we still don't know what Francis this
war will bring about this is a terrible
perspective
many difficult situations might come we
don't know
and uh in a certain moment the
opportunity comes and by that time will
not regret to have done this very
important work
yeah thank you very much and I will
focus again to see that many of the
proposals the citizens did give are
covered by a change of policies and the
commission took it up but there were
focused ones and proposals where the
citizens ask us to debate it and come up
with the proposal and I will highlight
Margarita two three examples with the
social progress protocol we will
rebalance economic and social rights and
that will be something we don't have yet
we also if we look at the health chapter
and the competences here it's one of the
experience of the pandemic that we need
and I always said everyone in the room
of the parliament and the others that
knows me I always say
from the beginning we didn't perceive
this as a Christmas tree but really
Maria said it very targeted treaty
changes essential to achieve that will
be necessary if we want to deliver more
and have a European Union capable to act
and I see also it will not be do magic
I mean also we have to be clear here but
essential and I always want to highlight
also to Pedro
um this is something in the beginning I
mentioned where we still have uh our
fights to do we will see how far we get
but also here with our proposals we
cannot do magic we have to do it we do a
package there's always something in a
package that is very good for some parts
and something that is not easy to
swallow that's how it works and we are
still working on this part uh here
especially but I think as Maria said we
now have some good examples that we did
in the pandemic and with the war to say
okay here we need a golden rule for
example and and in space and let me use
the opportunity again from the site of
the parliament and as one of the
rapporteurs to thank Maria and the Fabs
because in the whole process we had a
lot of intellectual support uh so during
the conference that was essential to do
our job here
properly so thank you again and I have
to leave you because I'm also the
repertoire of a very important social
file and we will have a shadow meeting
now to continue because we we don't give
up all the other things in policy areas
we still want social progress to be
achieved until the end of this plenary
and we will not give it up so thank you
very much and thank thank you also for
all the contributions
thank you Gabby
[Applause]
so we conclude the first panel and we
moved to the second panel which is new
Progressive policies for more solidarity
maybe we can invite
Permanente Perez Peter buffinger
nicoleta pirozi a Marco silento to come
to the table
ah they are online
this time
okay well so
um as uh you have seen these um a
seminar
has two Dimensions we have tackled
obviously not everything but the First
Dimension
the first I mentioned was devoted to the
institutional
part and this second one is uh the
policy aspect because as you know the
treaty has these two Dimensions the
things that we
give to the Union as a policy task but
also the institutional how we make the
decisions about this policy so
both in the com in the conference we
discuss
democracy and policies now uh the report
in which Gap is working tackles policies
but also the institutional side
for us a socialists the two are very
important so what we want is a more
social and more democratic Europe
so for the second aspect the the aspect
of the policies we have this uh second
panel and in the first place uh we have
uh UMES who is a former member of uh
dsmd group for 25 years
and also coordinator in the former
coordinator in the concomity but also a
member of the AFCO committee and now
also a member of the franco-german
expert group on EU reform the only thing
is uh this panel it's unlike the other
one it's four of you so please uh
try to be like
maybe no more than seven minutes so
there is time for everyone and then also
for debate thank you provanch the floor
is yours
thank you very much it's always a honor
and a pleasure to be uh among you
especially on these topics that uh
topics we always need to to address
um I share a single trunk in Paris where
we try to promote the French language so
I'm going to speak in French
and I believe most of you will be happy
with this
um
I'm not going to speak on behalf of the
franco-german working group
because
this is a group which was set up but I'm
sure you saw at the 60th anniversary of
the Elysee treaty
between Adamo and Lawrence born
who were the leaders of the European
Affairs in the two governments
now of course
we owe our conclusions to those two
ministers which we still haven't drawn
up
but I'd just like to tell you
normally we should have a little report
in before the summer and kind of an
interim report and then the final report
will come out in September
so right now this morning I'm speaking
on behalf I'm speaking personally thank
you for allowing me to participate in
this panel because this is the one that
we're really interested in and I'd like
to show my full agreement with Professor
Zac a that when he says legitimacy is
not just going to come from the
institutions but from the policies I
don't quite share that conclusion
or that assumption but I I didn't
actually make that conclusion but I
think he's right for all institutions
this is true but the European
institutions often they're further from
the citizens uh difficult to understand
because they're quite conflict the issue
of output and what purpose we have to
have common rules and common obligations
that the institutions have to do the
same thing it's a major question and all
of those who've uh worked with me know
how it is it's not that I'm tired of
institutional reform I think it's
intrinsically necessary but we can't
sell it politically you can't sell that
idea politically
not do we make the jump through the
political parties well because of the
situation or political partner parties
in uh European democracy I think we may
need to deal with another
uh field
where we've got more questions than
answers but based on our political
objectives how can we achieve this
and I heard what you said in the
previous table round instentions of
competence of the EU extending
competences for health environment
digital aspects on the budget uh
taxation Etc okay all well include but
if you look at the reality of what's
actually happening in the EU
well
do we always need do we does it always
have to go through a change in the
treaty I saw what happened uh during
covet where the commission with without
any mandate
in an area that they weren't competent
in was able to work with the treaties as
they were to require
European Pharmaceuticals Industries
member states and others
to accept
a
vaccine to be managed directly by the
Commission in a very directive way and
how to prepare the vaccine uh
manufacture and distribute it don't
forget that
let's not just see our failures but
let's see what's excessives we have had
because
well maybe because I was member of the
two conventions and you all know that
for the second convention I brought in a
conclusion which was not shared by
everybody buddy but I certainly learned
a lot
uh this is not the institutional party
that we've been dreaming of
do not believe that we're going to make
this great treaty and Professor exactly
it was right once again we can write up
the Spinelli treaty but don't think
we're going to be able to implement it
right away the citizens wrote up the car
in the cough
we pretty much agree with everything
that lucif uh said but do you think the
members one member states will buy the
whole thing do you think that one
members to every member State wants a
new convention
and that they'll buy it up well
sometimes we need symbols so
uh we need to have something that looks
like a convention but don't expect much
of it because the heads of government
and States hold the key we don't like it
but that's the way it is
and in their key something is going to
be imposed upon them
two things and this is our work in a way
of as a franco-german this is the rule
of law because that is the basis of the
EU democracy is the basis whether it is
not LED well
uh that may be true we're going to have
to do something because our treaty is
being weakened but whether we like it or
not
or seeing something like what we call
enlargement
and I agree again with Professor Jacque
uh there's a leverage here and then we
have the debate
should we have
uh
if it is what we do uh not through some
great evening but do we have to take
everything is enlargement imperative to
implement the rule of law should we put
it in a text before the enlargement or
in the enlargement text
I think we have to put it in the text
because
the treaties have to change when we have
the enlargement the number of uh MEPS
and the number of Commissioners you want
a package if you want to enlarge do it
but I'm just
speaking kind of my lingual heaven
I mean you have to look what we have to
put in these changes
if we want to move forward
we're going to be in a Europe of 35
now maybe it'll be like Spinelli it
might not be overnight but we're going
to reach 35 do you really think
we're going to be able to have the same
policies as we did before
remember what we did with the British so
they wouldn't disturbished it didn't we
didn't have a happy ending with the
British they might not come back right
away but one day
they uh they opted out of Europe but
that hasn't stopped us from moving
forward so we really need to think that
there's not going to be this overnight
change
and we have to decide on crucial issues
with uh a concept that we don't like I'm
a Cartesian and French I'm part of the
Marxist view but we're going to have to
be flexible and introduce flexibility
what does that mean well we need the
qualified majority ever we're keeping in
mind that the council always decides
everything
unanimous
unanimously and what look what happens
in the council they
come forward and they have these
so-called constructive abstentions which
took place on taxation
uh so certain areas related to foreign
trade
so in the institutional reforms the
major ones you've got the rule of law
which is an important issue
and we've got to uh
blow up the What's blocking the absolute
or qualified majority uh 152 against 151
but anyway we've got to have that in the
Vero stock uh report but I don't agree
with Maria here
re enforced cooperation the Pastoral
Clause are not flexibility tools they
actually are locks because we're not
able to use them so we've got to reflect
on the qualified majority a tailor-made
one which might be variable which won't
make things more simple but it will help
us succeed so that if a country that
doesn't want to participate doesn't
prevent others from doing it we don't
want blocking minorities but we just
want to not prevent them from reacting
thank you that's all I have to say
foreign
[Music]
for your contribution
is true that I would say
on the question of enlargement we need
to say that we also need the reform we
need to connect those two things
because we know that there are member
states who are very much in favor of
enlargement so for those groups of
member states we need to say yes but
you need to support us on any other part
but now
we will
move on to Peter buffinger
Who is the
chair for monetary policy and
international economics
at wilsburg University member of the
German Council of economic experts who
is going to speak online so please
Professor bofinger well thank you for
being with us again if you could stick
to
seven eight minutes
thank you very much for inviting me so
I'm joining you from the Canary Islands
where the connection is not perfect and
the only connection that I found to be
somehow stable is in is outside so if
you hear a bird interfering so please
excuse this okay so I will
I will talk about the economic Dimension
and the implications of the economic
dimension on treaty changes the next
slide please
thank you
and it's obvious that we are facing
unprecedented economic challenges right
now we are undergoing a great
transformation of the European economy
to factors which you all know climate
change decarbonization uh deployment and
development of renewable energy sources
we need alternative sources for
strategically important raw materials
they have digitalization we have
demographics
and what I think is very important we
have a growing strategic competition by
the China and the United States next
slide please
and I yeah I think it's really important
to have in mind that the challenge posed
by the United States is not only related
to the inflation reduction act but other
acts like the chips and science Act and
the B parties in in infrastructure law
uh which provide about
1.
1.3 billion uh sorry 1 300 billion of of
financing for investments in the United
States and as you can see uh on this on
this chart there are many many companies
now reacting to this offer by by the by
the US government
establishing new firms on on
semiconductors on uh on batteries and so
on and so on so I think this is a huge
challenge right now for for Europe if we
eat newspapers every day you can see new
companies saying okay uh we go to the US
because this financial
um
cities are so high so next slide what
does this mean we need physical space
for the financing of transformative
investments in the EU and whereas the
fiscal space come from well it can come
from the national level it can come from
intergovernmental
Arrangements any come come from the EU
level if you talk about the financial
space at the national level there are
two restrictions one are legal or
constitutional restrictions like just a
little growth fact like regulations on
state aid but there are also also Market
restrictions for countries with
relatively high debt levels so even if
you ease the legal restrictions some
countries are still facing Market
restrictions and these are of course
countries with relatively high debt
levels and therefore bodies required is
of course also fiscal space at the EU
level
either by EU Texas or I buy by by EU
debt
um next slide please
and as treaty changes at the national
level are required I I think the draft
by the snd group for a new article 126
uh is very useful emphasizing that it's
not only important to avoid deficits but
also to ensure the necessary Investments
to achieve the European economic social
and environmental objectives and I think
it's a good idea to say okay these
Investments should not be included in
the Bland or actual government deficit
or government debt uh in the in the
context of the Mask of the master
regulations I think this is very
important treaty change that is required
to give the breathing space at the at
the national level next please
um and um so what I think one might
might discuss is a concept of
project-based golden rules Maria spoke
of of of the necessity to include a
Golden Rule and I think it's important
to specify a golden rule to to necessary
Investments and these necessary
investments in my view could be defined
as projects
um
which which helped to to to to
finance EU Finance Investments which
have externalities for the whole you
like Maria said it and so the idea is
member states develop these develop
broad projects and these projects will
be approved by the by the commission and
monitored by the commission and once
these projects have the approval by the
commission they will then not be
included in the planned or actual
government deficit or government debt as
the s d draft invisible
next slide
uh of course we also need more fiscal
space at the EU level and in this regard
ngu was a was a paradigm shift which
should be the huge importance but so far
this
fiscal space that was was created by ngu
was was only Justified as an exceptional
response to Temporary but Extreme
circumstances so what we would need is a
new article I'm not a lawyer and an
economist but you know needs new article
in the treaty that provides this this
form of financing or phrasing its own
debt and and designing
um uh projects
as as a permanent as a permanent ability
uh and saying okay this form of
financing is is possible for long-term
Investments with high externalities like
climate change defense health and
infrastructure networks next please
yeah it can be short I think it's only
uh that is this is uh another proposal
by snd Group which strengthens the role
of the European Parliament in the
decision process on resources which I
very much appreciate next one please
and this is more or less the same next
please
um and here if I have one point where
I'm a little bit critical
uh with the S D draft and there's a
question whether the Mandate of the
European Central Bank should be widened
to ensure a high level of employment and
social brokers in addition to price
stability here I'm a little bit
skeptical because uh one if you have
demand shocks uh like decline like
Global recession
um in in such a shock employment and
inflation going into in the same
direction so there's no trade-off for
the central bank with employment and and
the price stability so in the case of
Iman shocks it's not necessary to
include something like this in the draft
in the case of Supply shock something we
are experiencing right now there is a
trade-off between inflation and
employment and and of course this
creates a huge problem for the central
bank to balance these two objectives but
if there's no longer a priority of price
stability over
uh employment then the uh the ECB can
never
deal with the with the job because in
order to fight Supply somehow must raise
interest rates what the ECB is doing
right now uh and um and uh this has at
least temporary negative employment
shocks the negative employment effects
so I think this is something one should
consider very very carefully so let me
include
um we are confronted with unprecedented
challenges and I think to deal with the
challenges huge private and public
Investments are needed and for this
ample fiscal space at the national ad as
well as at the union level is required
the current treaty has been able to
provide this space but only as an
exceptional and temporary measures and
therefore a new treaty must allow fiscal
space
as on a permanent basis and for the
Virgin growth fact this implies that
need this kind of project-based called
rules and at the EU level we need
something like ngeu 2.0 thank you very
much
thanks a lot uh Professor bofinger for
this very important suggestions and for
keeping with the time so now
um which is important also
um we have
um
next in the program is Nicoletta pilozi
which is head of the program on the
European Union and at Institute of our
internationally so again Professor or
expert birozi uh thanks a lot for your
participation and please if you can make
it in seven minutes thanks
um yes hope you can hear me
okay yes okay fine so good morning thank
you very much for inviting me to this
very interesting event and I'm very
sorry not to be able to join you in
person
uh so we agreed that the devil focus
more on defense and security aspects of
treaty reform and this is of course a
sector in which the balance between the
role of the institutions and member
states uh to which Professor Jacque was
referring is particularly relevant we
have to take into account when we think
about future reforms in the European
Union now we know that the Russian
aggression against Ukraine was a turning
point for European security and defense
and this is Ladder ready to
um some key steps forward in the defense
sector the European Union had decided to
finance uh the military support to the
Ukrainian government we had major
Decisions by member states for example
Germany that decided to
finance heavily the defense sector
Sweden and Finland that decided to join
NATO Denmark that decided to join the
csdp so uh time might be ripe for bolt
reforms and bold decisions in the field
of the feds we have to clarify first of
all what is our objective if we assume
that the objective is the creation of a
European Defense Union as it was also
suggested by uh the conference on the
future of Europe and by the European
Parliament we have to be clear on what
these uh entail and here I think that
the samalo Declaration from 1998 still
has some validity also in view of the
recent developments in the field of
defense
do you must have the capacity for
autonomous military action backed by
credible military forces the means to
decide to use them and a Readiness to do
so in order to respond to military
crisis while NATO as a predominant role
in the territorial defense of Europe
now if we look at this objective where
do we stand and what do we miss I think
the treaties are already very clear
about the fact that uh defense should be
linked to a truly common foreign and
security policy in the European Union as
it is foreseen for example in articola
24 so the European Defense Union cannot
be decoupled from a common foreign and
security policy this means intervening
on foreign and security policy
Provisions for example by expanding the
powers of the high representative and
also in incentivizing forms of
differentiated integration among member
states in the field of foreign policy
if we look at the at defense and foreign
policy matters of course we have an
issue with the decision-making process
we have seen already that unanimity as
very often led to late or sub-optimal
responses to crisis and conflicts and
this should be amended somehow so forms
of qualified majority voting we can
reflect what is the best formula as
Professor Jacque was suggesting should
be considered both in foreign policy and
in defense policy in the European Union
and I know that the European Parliament
there is a widespread consensus on these
however this is not enough
if we want a European Defense Union we
should also reinforce the legitimacy of
this policy in the eyes of citizens and
for the European Union overall that's
why the provisions of articola 36 in my
view should be somehow revised in order
to enhance the role of the European
Parliament in controlling and
supervising this policy we have seen
already some changes of course with the
Lisbon treaty but the intergovernmental
blueprint of the common security and
defense policy remain basically
unaltered and the European parliament's
role remains limited that's why I think
that information and consultation Powers
should be expanded but also budgetary
power of the European Parliament on
Military and defense matters we know
that nowadays on the basis of article of
the operations having military or
defense applications cannot be funded by
the common budget however this
impossibility
creates unbalanced burden sharing among
member states and simply those that are
more active are also those that are
paying the most for a military
interventions of the European Union and
also impedes the civilian military
cooperation that has been always one of
the objective of the European Union so I
think that common budget should be used
also for a military missions
um all the actions of the European Union
peacekeeping conflict prevention
strengthen International Security shall
be undertaken on the basis of the treaty
uh using capabilities provided by the
member states now I think this is
um something we cannot change in the
short media term it is not realistic to
overcome this this provision in the
short term for example through the
creation of a European Army however what
we need is a Clear Channel command to
mobilize effectively the European
National forces to be able to act also
in this time frame this means that we
need a political Authority which could
take the form of a council of European
Defense ministers we need a fully
fledged headquarter in Brussels for
military operations and not only for
non-executive Missions and we need also
National military contingency uncle that
can be mobilized by deu authorities
the European Defense Agency has a role
to play on these and should be turned in
this new architecture into a truly
European armaments agency and this leads
me to the final point also because I see
that the time is running short
um I think that investments in the
defense sector should be allowed through
the common budget because this is the
only way that would allow the European
Union to com to overcome the current
ambiguity and inefficiencies and I give
a few examples at the moment defense
Investments by the European Commission
in particulate by Digi deathies are done
in a purely Market logic but defense is
not a free market Investments are done
taking into account political and
strategic considerations so I think that
3D changes should allow the European
commission to invest strategically but
of course with a correctly balanced role
for the member states which actually own
armed forces and the European Parliament
for Democratic control over the European
Commission the lack of a stable
budgetary framework has led us to use
enough budget instruments such as the
European peace facility for short-term
support to Ukraine and now for joint
ammunition procurement we have
instruments such as the EDF but also
Edith
which are not framed in a coherent
architecture but respond more to haddock
and short-term political purposes so I
think that all these reasons call for a
rationalization of Defense architecture
but also defense budget and this should
be done partially also through 3D
changes I will stop here thank you
for that very interesting
presentation concerning defense and uh
the reforms which are very pertinent
because of the Russian against
aggression against Ukraine
and respecting
the uh timing so we can finish the span
panel more or less at 12. and we'll have
the debate we'll have to be taking place
without interpretation unfortunately
because the interpreters will uh
conclude but at 12 I will give the floor
to Marcos celonso who's the head of
international policy
of the European Federal Federation of
trade unions which we've been working
with
and look at vicentino really played in
this very active role coming to all the
pleneries on the conference on the
future of Europe expressing the
commitment to really help out you have
the floor monocle
no more than seven minutes I think I
have just five minutes of interpretation
I will do my best first of all
um uh I we supported here that probably
we must try to go to a revision of
European treaties is difficult
of course but I think is really the
moment
um people have I mean in the conference
to Future Europe we have found also with
citizens with all the actors
participating the right challenges and
we have seen what that we were in a new
phase in a new momentum probably we
um or
in the follow-up of the conference
official European people are not
considering that this new challenges
including the Investments that people
have uh already mentioned it's needed a
a total change in the way we are
financing these Investments how we are
financing change uh just keep in mind
the doubling of your budget immediately
one thousand uh billion Euro to finance
investment with the European debts uh
um let's say flexibility in the public
budget almost 10 percent of GDP are
located to Temporary measures to uh to
to respond to the coffee crisis and then
to the war in Ukraine and worry
Ukrainian subsidies to companies is 1.5
percent of GDP coordinated by the EU or
authorized by the U and still with the
sustainable Finance framework we have
the ideal law as the ambition to
orientate the Investments for one third
of the financial Market if the financial
Market will respond positively so can
you imagine how much money moves from
the new decision to company people Etc
and this cannot be done
in the future with the current rules for
one simple reasons I will try to be very
short because I don't have time we are
deciding in emergency the U.S competence
because it's deciding in emergency we
cannot plan these interventions and we
cannot consider all aspects of
sustainability when we decide what to do
with these Investments
because we are only generating in
emergency all the time so we need
instruments that
allow us to plan
uh the the the the way we use the money
another thing is
if we want to change the way we produce
work and consume because this is what we
are trying to do with this huge amount
of money we need those who produce it
those who work and consume on board the
social partners and employers
represented these workers representative
must be part of this process the current
rules do not allow the social patterns
to be always at the center of the
process and Frankly Speaking is very
difficult to have a just transition to
have the transition without us
and this is something that you can I
mean regardless of different capacity we
have a national level to go uh to
perform industrial relations this is
something that we have to put on board
otherwise it will be very difficult to
have the green transition to go for a
strategic autonomy or to address the
demographic change all things that were
being addressed in the list of things
that
um Gabriel Bishop puts as a reason and
also Rodriguez put us a list of things
that needs
a revision of the traces there is also
another aspect that we have to consider
the word security
Now people also we see in our movement
the people ask for security
of course we cannot intend security also
only as uh the fear of the external
enemy that today is materialized we can
succeed you know in in the open
strategic autonomy agenda insecure only
if we conceive the security word in at
least three dimensional health
because the coverage is still there
showed that we were very poor in
protecting our people the health of
people so this is crucial we have to
find a new way to enhance the action in
the health sector income protection
and of course defense and security as
our experts said few moments ago but if
we don't have these three dimension it's
impossible to continue and to provide
their answer to people the answer they
want it will be always partial so I
don't know if the treaties are equipped
to that surely the Pastoral Clauses can
help difficult to activate but surely
the treaty has been conceived to be an
alive body of norms and rules uh and
probably there is space there to uh to
accommodate certain things but more in
general let's try to think also to what
rules we can change in the treaty to do
what
another two things that in my view are
crucial one is to make more solids the
social dimensional of the you one idea
is coming from your proposals and
including the pillar in the treat of
course the pillar the European peel of
social rights cannot in my view must be
smartly included in the treaty because
the the pillar must be remains something
that can evolve in the course of time
because it's already seven years you
mentioned digital probably someone so we
but we can mention the the necessity to
have a Perma into social program
despite the model like the European
people of social rights can be the model
but the this program must be there
otherwise we will not have uh the
effects we want and the other thing is
consider that the current rules have
been interpreted basically in two way
the uh since the last 30 change in 2006.
one was the years of austerity where
people were managing mistrust
it was the the the time of egoism no
yeah reality our round table is called
about solidarity we have experienced it
with the same illegal framework and
someone said that with the same legal
framework we had the period of
solidarity and sustainability in the
last four years in simulation of
emergency but yeah so the same rules to
to serve two different views that is why
probably many of us have tried to talk
about the social progress protocol to
include a tool that can help all of us
to interpret to to mean the European
Union mainly as an instrument of
solidarity and not as an instrument that
tried to put under control the all our
egoism that can be expressed by national
governments or by groups of interests
but this is important to have these
tools in the treaties how to go toward
the treaty and I will go to the end of
my speech I mean we don't have to do
everything at once you remember
Amsterdam a massive times that means
this one if we have the ambition to
change everything in one single chain is
impossible but if we are as smart enough
to imagine something that in the course
of the time in two three times can uh
bring us to the EU we want and many
other challenges have been mentioned
probably we can succeed
I hope I cover more or less the points I
wanted thank you
many thanks Marco
um and many things for the interpreters
also for staying a few minutes after the
hour to at least complete the panel with
interpretation now we we move on to the
debate
um I I take also advantage of the last
comments by uh by Marco because since uh
we we hear
um still among some colleagues I will
not say the majority in the group but in
any event important voices that are not
fully convinced of I will say the
majority view in favor of of a new
treaty that is more social and more
Federal well precisely if I I will say
if we are
um coherent with our own ideological
position which is to rebalance the
market freedoms in the union with the
social rights
um and living outside the discussion on
qualified majority voting and so on that
we have had
that in itself
implies a treaty change because we
cannot incorporate the European pillar
of social rights or the social progress
protocol into the treaty without
changing the treaty so if we ask you
know pure social Democrats and we don't
even want to talk about decision making
about more powers to the parliament no
which is more like
the traditional Federalist program but
then let's think of the
of the social Dimension so can we really
achieve our goals as social Democrats
without uh rebalancing in the treaty
Market freedoms with with social rights
I don't think it's possible but of
course it's up to the colleagues also to
to see uh if there are other views to
achieve this of course the European
pillar of social rights that was
approved in Gothenburg was a big
achievement Maria joa played a big role
because she led the report in the in
this Parliament about this but this as
you know it's a non-binding document
important but non-binding so I I think
this is just one example we can think of
others but uh I give now the floor to
the members Maybe pasca
but Pascal didn't have the chance in the
first round it was his fault because he
was late but uh
please Pascal no I was joking please
when you are talking about the social
peer uh why
nothing about sustainability and
environmental issues it's I think we we
are 20 23 so uh where is the social
possibility an issue
uh without a question of sustainability
so I I yes because I read the draft and
then the draft took about the social
issues and of course it's very important
but maybe for the snd it's important to
to take the question of sustainability
too but so
it was my only point
uh or there yes
um
impossibility
[Music]
foreign
democracy or the institutions
Mercy I'm margarita
thank you very much I'd like to to raise
one point linked with the presentation
of Professor Peter boffenger my point is
on the role of department so there are
clearly two deficit of uh capacity of
the parliament to act
the first one is in the framework of
article 122. it means it was the article
used for different Financial initiatives
to answer to crisis okay it was very
well done but the role of department is
zero it means the parliament has no role
when the budget the the legal framework
is article 122. I'm not so on to to to
have concrete points on article
122 as a professor proposed but I think
that it must clarify the role of
Department my second point is also on
the role of Department it means on the
revenue side of the EU budget the role
of the department has no role and I
think that this is something that must
be modified of course from when uh one
point any other Parliament could mind
could found different initiatives for
example to create rrf working group but
we did it because we demand it it's not
theophys it's not because we have the
role to do it
thank you
yeah those are very good examples that
you that you cannot solve within the
Lisbon treaty
because password you cannot apply it to
the own resources because it's only
consultation and then in article 122
there is not even consultation it's only
the decision by by the Council on
issuing that which is a I don't know a
Pedro yeah well just one short question
for Provence Beres
glad to see you back in the parliament
um I see you're not particularly
enthusiastic about the idea of Street
change
just a little bit perhaps
but if anything can make the difference
is the enlargements so but even in case
of the enlargement if I understood
correctly the ambitious ambition of
treating change should be
limited meaning it should be targeted
what kind of agenda
would you think that would be viable in
the context of enlargement in terms of
treaty change
mark
no other
okay but thank you for coming any other
questions from the room
no okay well then we will go uh to the
answers by the panelists in reverse
order so uh Marco
no just one remarkable sustainability I
didn't get time but for me the answer is
very clear that U.N 2030 agenda
sustainable development goals our point
of reference now there is the reform of
the economic governance uh with the
legislative package hopefully if the
patiently package will arrive this will
be for me a test because there will be
uh the possibility include for us the
pillar is the sdga central approach to
sdgs I couldn't tell it but it's
officially our strategy
um it's a test because you have a huge
change in the radio operates the
parliament is sometimes involved for sun
Sultana certain legislative pieces is
involved for certain analysis knots so
it's really a test for me for the future
of Europe uh this reform let's see but I
fully agree
well just to complement that in the work
that Gap is doing in the report we have
a socialist we have proposed a climate
neutrality to be added to the treaty
um I don't know if this goes in the
category of uh the ball and that
Professor Jackie said before like nice
to have but you should know that the
Lisbon treaty doesn't mention climate
change because it's a reflection of of
its time which is paradoxical it's only
there is a general chapter on
environment but nothing specifically on
fighting climate change so we have to
take this into account
um now will be nicoleta
defense so I think I will leave it there
okay well you could always add something
because I'm sure that with seven minutes
uh so but okay thank you then
um it's a professor buffinger that there
was a question by the way on that this
is also important because
um there is also a bit The View
pervanche but then you can also
you you have the last word uh in the
order but this is a but when you mention
what happened with the kovit there is
this idea that the the treaty is kind of
chewing gum and that you have the
political will you can do everything but
be careful with the grammar because the
German constitutional Court which of
course I don't recognize legitimacy is
the European court but they have said
recovery plan is a one-off if you want
to do it permanently you have to change
the treaty in our view okay so let's not
think that we can well we can do a lot
with political will the treaty has many
flexibility but maybe uh we can go to
the breaking point so if we want to have
a permanent capacity I think it's very
relevant Professor bofinger what do you
explain
yeah thank you very much
um yeah in my shortening I only want to
say that we need to redesign the
treaties in order to make a permanent
facility possible not only as the kind
of exceptional crisis device and of
course this could also would also have
to include a important role of of the
parliament in this process
foreign
yes this is a critical point because
this is what we want to what we said to
achieve also as a political group even
before the conference which is the to go
to a full federalization on a more
complete federalization which means that
the parliament has more equal Powers
with Council when it comes to approving
the budget on the revenue side as uh
Margarita reminded but also on Taxation
and on debt those are the three the
three key points that the traditional
Parliament is entitled to to decide on
but once you have the last word
um thank you there were several uh
question raised where I would like to
answer but before doing this
I would like uh to to share with you
some some thoughts the treaty change
will not happen overnight
because uh in my understanding it the
leverage will be the enlargement treaty
so this is the the the the time frame
and ahead of this time frame uh you're
allowed to think short mid-term and long
term and let's say that the enlargement
will be the long term uh even though we
need it to be as quick as possible but
this means you also I think you should
also think what could be asked to the
last useful presidency which is the
Spanish one
what do we expect from them because they
are the one who are going to settle
the scene for the debates uh in in the
campaign so it's a very critical one
and second in terms of time frame to my
understanding I'm sure you have a full
list of item you want to be dealed with
in the next mandate but for me the next
mandate
uh the the Cornerstone of the next
mandate is not is not next Generation EU
even though this is what I would like
but the reality is going to be get
prepared for the enlargement this is
going to be the one and this is where uh
you have an Avenue uh to to Define what
you want in terms of institutional uh
treaty change
when it comes to um
I was of course very pleased to have be
on the same virtual round table with sir
Professor brofinger
um but I think there's one dimension
that was not mentioned and I cannot
leave this room without mentioning it
which is the question of the one who
knows me will not be surprised
Aggregates fiscal stance
because all the debate I can see
are now focused on a bilateral
discussion between member State and the
commission and this is more than
dangerous
it's helpful somehow because then you
can introduce some tailor-made
adaptation of the requests but
you give up the broad overview and the
room for solidarity and interconnection
between the economies and you cannot
leave this uh only to the commission I
mean if you if you kill this you kill
any space for real solidarity
and going back to the treaty change
please when you will go through and I'm
sorry because maybe I went too quickly
through the Amendments that were
proposed by the group for the hofstadt
report I didn't see anything about the
appointment and the nomination process
in the ECB and blah blah blah but it's a
point you should never
forgive the parliament got a new power
when it comes to the SSM uh SRM um
and all the other stuff we have built
since the banking Union you should have
the same when it comes to the ECB member
now on the management of Crisis you
fully right we need to have something if
we have a treaty change
we need to have something about price
management except you know where the
crisis
a crisis something you have not expected
that's going to happen that is happening
so all you you always have to be quite
flexible uh agile as we say now
um and reactive but you're right there's
a point here that we need to to take in
track of
um last point on the uh on the outcome
and the policies
and then I will answer Pedro
um
and it's a pointer I share with
Professor bothinger uh I think
on the Avenue of uh the solution put on
the table because of the kovid was uh
the borrowing capacity
and also never forget sure
these are two very very important tools
that for our political family is an
achievement
that we need to fight to make sure for
many many reasons that I don't have time
to develop here
to Sherry as a asset that we need to
consolidate but for this it's the same
as the social pillar this is not the
question is not to have it uh uh written
in the treaty
the the question is how to decide on
such policies
because for example on on and if you
write the social pillar in in the for
example if I had to do something about
this social issue
I would much more insist to have
qualified majority for 151 52 and 53
and another hierarchy of norms of
standards because today as you know
social standards article 9 is useless
because social standards they come after
the free movement of goods people and
capital
and this is this is a real issue
but to write the social pillar in in the
treaty
in 10 years we will have to come back
because oh in five years old in three
years and it was already mentioned that
on the digital Dimension it's not there
enough
so to to and this is this why this was
the reason why I said no to the
Constitution huh because it was putting
in the Constitution
policies
and this is not the place the policies
is the dynamic you have in in the
discussion between political families or
in particular among political groups
what you need to put in the treaty are
the way the the the the rules for the
the common Behavior
uh but
and it's the same about the the the the
the the the the
environmental Dimension that uh Pascal
mentioned of course you need to add
climate but then you also need to add a
biodiversity please don't forget this
one
including when it refers to health so I
think to fight for content of policies
in the treaty change this is not the
best I mean for me this is not the
priority the The Leverage that we can
have when we have the treaty change is
to make decision making easier
this is why I think I've already
mentioned it in the beginning but I will
come back to this
the question of enhanced cooperation and
the password Clause needs to be
Revisited because they don't work and
the spirit in which I would like us to
be able to to revisit them is to make
sure that no member states can block a
decision where a majority wants to go
and that somehow you can build an a
constructive abstention or or
non-participation or de facto
non-participation because otherwise you
would not be able to to move ahead and
of course it doesn't mean that if you
put all item under qmv that the decision
will be by qmv but and Professor very
rightly said it in the council even when
there's a field in qmv they don't vote
they don't go over it's not like in the
parliament in the parliament when you're
fed up with a discussion you close the
discussion you put a deadline and you go
for the vote
in the council they don't do it like
this they go on discussing discussing uh
until they understand there's a majority
there
and even if you have on the paper qmv it
will go on happening like this so the
only thing you need to to make sure is
that the two three or four country among
35 that will be completely against will
keep silent and will not uh oppose
um so this is the first basket which is
for me very important qmv
close password and uh enhanced
cooperation
a second is rule of law
you need to do something out of this
because otherwise including in our ex I
mean put your house in order before you
can tell to the world that they have to
follow your own rules in terms of
democracy freedom and blah blah blah and
the third package package is of course
the institution setting it was not on
the agenda this morning but the question
of the dimension of the commission
uh the representation of the member
states in the human Parliament the
subject I think you know by heart this
of course is a must do in the next uh
treaty thank you so much
foreign
by way of a very short uh conclusion
because I think this has come up of the
discussion sometimes uh politicians we
focus too much I will say in the either
of either or right and but also as a
Social Democratic family we have to uh I
will say be cognizant that we have been
I will say the political family I will
say more successful in Europe precisely
for uh making creative synthesis
starting with the social dimension of
the market economy
um so I will say uh there is no
opposition between
fully exploiting the Lisbon treaty
but also identifying uh the points that
are lacking and that we need uh with
another future more federal and social
treaty
second
enlargement and depending going hand in
hand this is very important this is a
big leverage to achieve the new
constitutional yes yeah I agree to
achieve the new
um constitutional treaty and and also no
opposition between the improvements on
content on policies and the Improvement
on decision making and that this goes to
the point that you emphasize qualified
majority voting I think it's a big
priority for all of us so three very
important elements that I think we have
to put together in our political uh
puzzle and all these done of course and
this goes to the intervention by
Professor Jake in a very legally sound
way so if we put all this together I
think we have a great
program ahead of us so thanks a lot to
all of you that participated today to
the MEPS also that came today Pedro
Silva and Pascal Durant the last one the
stand ending but also to Mark and
Margarita
to the panelists pervanch and Marco in
the room and Nicoletta and buffinger
online and also to the staff that made
this this possible
Sandrine Stephanie Francesco and
Alejandro I don't know if others have
been involved I don't want to so to all
those involved a part of the ones
mentioned and uh we continue with future
activities thanks